hey guys Pete here quick little Twin
Peaks update video today as many of you
saw on my social media accounts I posted
that the DVD pre-order is out for what
used to be called Twin Peaks season 3
it's interesting because they put the
official artwork out which was similar
to what we had already seen but now it
says Twin Peaks limited event series
instead of season 3 or the return well
you know exactly what extras are on it
now we I mentioned some of these in my
last video about the DVD set but we have
confirmation on that now and a little
bit more of an idea what's on there
before I jump into that though I want to
mention that there was actually some
season 4 news this week nothing concrete
or anything like that but mark frost was
interviewed by indieWIRE and they asked
him if that was something that was in
the works he said that he hasn't decided
if the show will come back for a fourth
season but it is being considered to
quote what he said Frost said I haven't
decided yet
I think it's still an open question and
it's one we're looking at and one that I
think Showtime is musing as well so we
already knew that David Lynch hadn't
ruled it out he said it was too early
basically it would take a long time but
he never said that they weren't gonna do
it and he said if that did happen that
fans would have to be patient we know
that you know it took about four and a
half years to put together what we saw
in season three which is what I'm still
calling the return which is now called
the limited event series because that
just isn't very descriptive at all so
that's good news if not great news you
know as I think that there's it feels
like they may do it I don't know you
know I don't know if there's a way to
actually separate my enthusiasm for the
series without just you know looking at
it with rose-colored glasses or whatever
but the fact that Lynch didn't say no
show time definitely said they were
interested in working with Lynch more
now mark frost saying that he hasn't
decided and that showtimes talking about
it or thinking about it is all good news
so the DVD is coming
I'll have the pre-order link in the
description of this video would be great
if you clicked on my link before you
ordered it because that helps me out
some what are we actually gonna get well
we know we're getting all 18 episodes of
this last season I talked about in the
last video about the 10 short films that
were released the names were released by
the rating company in Britain I won't
read all the names again but they are
being directed by a guy named Jason s
he's actually someone who shot a lot of
the footage for David Lynch the art of
life and we did get one piece of one of
the clips and it's basically behind the
scenes David Lynch is setting up the
scene that's in the motel in the
alternate dimension with Diane and coop
it's really fun to watch because of you
know they're talking about he's having
them do a kissing scene and you know
they're talking about blue velvet how
long ago that was and everything so it's
pretty interesting there's not a lot of
other details about what's gonna be in
these other clips but this is the one
that was titled the man with the grey
elevated hair which was obviously like
probably about David Lynch you know so
this is him setting up a scene and I
don't know if that gives us any more of
an idea of what we will see in the other
clips but my favorite part of it was is
that you heard him talking to them and
he calls Kyle kale and he calls Diane
tidbit you know those are things that I
had heard that he called them but had
never really heard him say it out loud
so that's kind of good beyond those 10
shorts the full panel from the comic-con
at 2017 is gonna be on there that's over
an hour long Damon Lindelof who was one
of the brains behind the series Lost was
the moderator of that and the actors who
were there are comic Lachlan Tim Roth
Naomi Watts
Dana ashbrook Kimmy Robertson Matthew
Lillard Everett McGill James Marshall
and Dawn Marie this will also include
the introduction
the David Lynch did they've released
this already but you know he wasn't at
comic-con so he made a short film and
there that'll be on the DVD as well
there's a three-part documentary it's
put together by Showtime it's called
Twin Peaks the phenomenon those are
about five minutes each roughly and
there's also a behind-the-scenes photo
gallery you'll be able to see all 18
variations of the Rancho Rose
productions screen indent there as the
collection of David Lynch produced Twin
Peaks promos there's seven of those I
mentioned behind the red curtain in my
last video but I didn't really
understand what it was there was news
that it was season 1 stuff it's actually
2 featurettes that are about a half an
hour a piece that were shot by Richard
de mer on the Red Room set that's the
actor who plays Ben Horne I don't know
anything more about those at this time
but that sounds kind of good everything
before that these two featurettes which
are called behind the red curtain and I
had bad milk in Dehradun everything that
I mentioned before that are on the DVD
this is actually a blu-ray exclusive and
then there's another blu-ray exclusive
called a very lovely dream one week in
Twin Peaks and this is a half an hour
little feature and that's from locations
in Washington State where they shot
outdoors in the first weeks of this in
2015 but also way back when they did the
original pilot so it's basically packed
with extra stuff the blu-rays $64.99 in
the US for US customers and the DVD is
$53.99 like I said I'll have a link in
the description that you can click on to
check it out it wasn't available for a
pre-order in Europe originally but it is
now so if you haven't checked back you
can get that now the one other thing
about when you when you pre-order on
Amazon if the price drops you don't get
screwed they actually change it for you
so it makes a lot of sense to preorder
as soon as possible because then
you're sure that if the price goes up
you have the lowest price but as the
price goes down you don't lose anything
either please like this video if you
enjoyed it please think about signing up
over on patreon if you're following my
season 1 re-watch or if you like the
other shows I do make sure you subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already
turn on notifications by clicking on the
little bell there so you know when the
next video comes out follow me on
Twitter and my other social media
accounts so that you can interact with
me in real time and thanks for watching
guys I'll talk to you soon